el presidente Gustavo Petro confirmó que
fueron hallados los cuatro menores de 11
meses y cuatro nueve y Trece años que
estaban desaparecidos desde el pasado
Primero de Mayo en esa fecha se perdió
la avioneta cesna en la que viajaban con
su madre y otras dos personas que se
accidentó en una densa selva del
suroccidente del país para ampliar este
tema me acompaña en estudio mi compañero
lluís Muñoz lluís bienvenido usted
estuvo en la zona informando sobre este
caso qué detalles se conocen un día
feliz Valentina y no estamos siempre
acostumbrados en Colombia dar este tipo
de noticias como un rescate que es ya
milagroso histórico para el país han
sido 40 días como bien comentaba usted
en una selva donde llueve 16 horas al
día siempre es de noche y nunca antes
había sido explorada por el nombre es
por eso que es tan espectacular que unos
niños hayan podido sobrevivir allá
Gustavo Petro el presidente de Colombia
llegó a llegó a Colombia precisamente
después de estar en Cuba esta mañana
firmando un acuerdo de cese al fuego con
la guerrilla activa más antigua América
Latina el eln y nada más llegar se ha
entero de la noticia ha dicho que es un
día mágico una palabra muy importante en
Colombia ha dicho que están los niños en
San José del guaviare que según como
vayan los chequeos médicos se los va a
poder trasladar a Bogotá o a
villavicencio donde están los abuelos y
familiares y vamos a escuchar qué más ha
dicho en su llegada aquí a Bogotá Bueno
hoy hemos tenido un día mágico
indudablemente llena de alegrías
acercarnos y tocar la paz
en el acuerdo que avanza con el eln y
ahora
regreso y la primera noticia es que
efectivamente
las comunidades indígenas que estuvieron
en la búsqueda y las fuerzas militares
conjuntamente
encontraron a los niños 40 días después
estaban solos habían sido ellos mismos
lograron un ejemplo de sobrevivencia
total digamos que quedará en la historia
así que esos niños son hoy los niños de
la paz y los niños de Colombia eran las
palabras del presidente Gustavo Petro
nosotros a esta hora conectamos con
Astrid Cáceres ella es directora del
instituto colombiano de bienestar
familiar la entidad encargada de la
protección integral de la infancia en
Colombia Astrid bienvenida France 24 lo
primero que queremos saber cómo están
los niños
sé que están bien sé lo que dijo el
presidente efectivamente lo van a
revisar en una ambulancia medicalizada y
dependiendo de eso para Bogotá pero
sobre todo sé que que tenemos que tener
un compromiso para cuidarlos
profundamente en este país que tenemos
que lograr que por cada niño se mueva al
mundo y que podamos hacerlo como lo
hicimos en este caso realmente esto es
muy feliz estoy en carretera
machacado allá Santa Marta hasta que
estaba en una ranchería en maicao y
recibir la noticia ya y saber que cada
cosa que hagamos tiene que tener impacto
es para mí maravilloso
astrito usted está ahora en el norte del
país en el Caribe nosotros coincidimos
en San José del guaviare en calamar en
plena selva y estuvimos conversando
sobre la importancia de esta misión como
ha dicho Queríamos saber quién los
encontró Y qué es lo primero que han
podido saber de mano de los niños sobre
cómo han podido sobrevivir
en general está con toda la información
del detalle Yo realmente no he logrado
la comunicación que quisiera para saber
el nivel de detalle de lo que pasó en
este momento
sé lo mucho de lo que hablamos y que
había que recoger parte de esta historia
porque realmente son unos niños muy
particulares y es muy importante lo que
está pasando pero el nivel de detalle
cómo nos encontraron no tiene el general
y lo tiene la tropa y La tropa indígena
que está allá pero yo no he podido
lograr comunicación con ellos haciendo
referencia otra vez al encuentro que
tuvimos en calamar en la base aérea
desde donde han salido los indígenas los
militares y donde También usted estuvo
en en el terreno usted me dijo que
confiaban mucho desde el gobierno en las
creencias ancestrales
Sí es que es que aquí hay que confiar
muchísimo en La Voz de las familias en
la forma como el corazón no Uno guiando
y como también eso mezclado con la
sabiduría indígena y con la sabiduría
militar tenía que dar resultados
realmente Esa fue siempre la esperanza
pero no se vale solo la táctica militar
sino hay un corazón con las familias
sino hay una conexión con sus creencias
y creo que esa fue la apuesta que
hicimos bueno el 17 de mayo pasado
Gustavo Petro tuiteo que se habían
encontrado estos niños no Un día después
borró el tuitter y dijo que había sido
una información errónea desde su
institución Cómo terminó este episodio
Ay perdón un segundo porque es que me
están llamando presidencia un segundo
son las cosas del directo Valentina
tenemos que recordar que desde las
instituciones militares se han Unido con
los indígenas algo inédito que no era
muy habitual en Colombia donde estas
organizaciones como la guardia indígena
estaban más acostumbradas a estar
enfrentadas con los militares en
terrenos muy alejados pero se han Unido
y además se han encontrado todo tipo de
métodos para encontrar a los niños han
reproducido en lengua indígena mensajes
de la abuela se han lanzado paquetes de
comida se han lanzado flyers han puesto
silbatos se han llevado también